welcome back to the rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Loki season 2 might be the MCU
title I am most excited for in 2023 with
a trailer I was able to see a d23
hopefully coming any day now but we just
got significant updates not only a new
villain being played by Kate Dickey but
an update about we're going to rent
Slayer that Clues us into the status of
the TBA after it was warped in the
season one finale which interestingly
Ray contextualized the mysterious shot
from That season 2 trailer so in this
video I'm gonna break down this season 2
News how one could escape the TVA truly
how many tvas there are or if there is
just one TBA you know I'm essentially
just gonna explain the whole geography
of the MCU time stream and Multiverse
it's no biggie okay this week we're
going to rensslayer actor gugu babatarah
told Entertainment Tonight quote it's
been amazing to shoot the second season
of Loki fans are gonna be in for a real
treat because the show is bolder and
more surreal in many ways it goes to
some bigger Bolder places than season
one which is really exciting in Loki
ravona is a powerful presence selfishly
rinselayer makes it out of the TVA which
I'm really excited about makes it out of
the TVA you say when we last Saw
Rensselaer she fought Mobius in the
season one finale and opened a Time door
to leave from the TBA to somewhere we
thought in the sacred timeline or a
timeline not so sacred anymore that it
started to unravel yep you're right
back here again
go ahead
where are you gonna go
in search of free will
so it's interesting for rinselayer to
have fully escaped the TBA because even
time doors aren't supposed to be Escape
hatches to a real world where you would
be fully saved from future interference
by the TBA like think about it would it
be even possible to actually escape the
TBA as soon as you leave it it wouldn't
really be that hard for the TVA to
locate you open up another time door to
where and when you are and drag you back
in the exception of course was Sylvie
who was only able to avoid capture from
the TVA because she figured out a
loophole that the TBA didn't even think
of until Loki movie has deduced it by
constantly moving and hiding in
apocalyptic events so to truly escape
the TBA red Slayer could also be hiding
in apocalyptic events or as a
high-ranking judge of the TVA she might
have access to some other temporal
technology that makes her invisible to
TVA detection like Frodo hiding from the
eye of Sauron and that could be the role
of kihue Kwan's character who is rumored
to be named oroborus AKA Bo the head of
Technology the TBA remember Nora Boris
for first of the image of a snake eating
its own tail symbolizing the eternal
life which neatly reflects both the
sacred timeline Loop and the inverted
Mobius strip that we're pretty sure
Mobius and Mobius was named after so
rensslayer could have stolen something
from the TBA technology archive that
allows her to navigate the time stream
without the TVA following her something
that I assume other Kang variants would
have this idea of escaping the TVA also
suggests that there's only one TVA in
Loki season 2 which would be a
significant confirmation because before
we were not totally clear how to
interpret the final scene of season 1 in
which Sylvie booted Loki from The
Citadel at the end of time and Loki
found himself in what seemed like a
changed DVA where Mobius and B15 had no
memory of him and the statutes of the
timekeepers were replaced with a statue
of Kang the Conqueror so what did this
mean was the TVA that we assumed was a
neutral space located in the null time
zone independent of any warpable
timeline actually one of an infinite
amount of tpas assigned to each Universe
capable of being changed by historical
medley lean in the past well I'm about
to Rod's quote actually shed some light
on the imagery we saw in the Loki season
2 footage where Loki uses a pruning
stick to prune away a tile tapestry wall
of the TVA and behind it are faces of
Jonathan Majors as Kang so that would
imply the TVA could have been
redecorated by simpler means than time
travel and time meddling by peeling back
the layer of the timekeeper statues to a
Kang layer that was always there for all
time always now I'm online you're online
everybody's online right now it's
YouTube why should the us or the UK have
anything to do with it well expressvpn
gets that where you are physically
shouldn't be a factor in where you go
digitally expressvpn lets you change
your online location with just a few
simple clicks for instance wanna
re-watch the original Spirited Away
before catching up on the new
live-action version well if you live in
the U.S none of Studio ghibli's films
are available on Netflix unless you have
expressvpn with expressvpn I can change
my location from the US to the UK and
get all the Studio Ghibli that I want
expressvpn invest in only premium
servers making them consistently faster
than other VPN providers and it is
physically impossible for those same
servers to store any logs of your
activity expressvpn masks your device's
unique IP address making it much more
difficult for big Tech and advertisers
to match your activity back to you
collect your data and sell it to
advertisers without your consent that
means expressvpn lets you get more
content more security and more privacy
all without sacrificing speed no wonder
CNET The Verge Mashable and tech radar
have all rated it as their number one
VPN find out how you can get three
months of expressvpn for free by
visiting expressvpn.com new rockstars or
by clicking the link in the description
below it could just be that there is
just one TBA but a TVA governed by
Clockwork magic that with a turn of a
master key somewhere could be rebooted
or reset however the current boss sees
fit so a warp TVA doesn't necessarily
mean that we are in a new timeline based
on a different Kang in the distant past
having changed it from its origin points
we are just in the same TVA with new
ownership it in a reset button the
service is pruning away and the Chrono
monitor is rebooted to their source code
we know that Jonathan Majors is
returning as Kang in Loki season 2. but
for only two episodes despite his face
I'm sure all over the set elsewhere so
is this new boss of the TBA a Kang
variant or could the big bad be someone
who like he who remains using the smoke
screen of the timekeepers someone who
uses the smoke screen in the Fearsome
facade of Kang to instill fear and
discipline in their toiling workers
while themselves remaining someone
behind the curtain someone like the
mystery villain played by Kate Dickey
for the season now remember Kate Dickey
played lady Liza Aaron on Game of
Thrones in the mother in the 2015 horror
film The Witch she's not only a great
actress she also looks a bit like a
slightly older Sofia dimartino she could
be playing a variant of Sylvie who took
Kang's deal you remember which deal I'm
talking about there's two options one
kill me and destroy all this and you
don't just have one devil you have an
infinite amount or
YouTube
run the thing now remember this will be
we saw in the Loki season one finale
didn't take the deal she killed he
remains and destroyed the sacred
timeline but since even Loki and
Sylvie's entrance to the Citadel in
their conversation with he remains was
scripted part of his sacred timeline
plan there might be another variant of
Sylvie who took up he remains on his
offer to take over the TVA and the way
Soviet leaders would adore in their
towns with murals and statues of people
like Stalin and Lenin to keep order this
boss now uses Kang space to crack the
whip on this rebooted TVA a little
preview announcement here I will
actually be revisiting the six episodes
of Loki season one in the comprehensive
deep dive in the New Year in a way that
I think you're all going to be really
excited about I can't say too much about
it now but stay tuned in January we're
going to be announcing some really big
stuff comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Tick Tock Hive
Instagram and Twitter follow the new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye foreign
[Music]